Only because of his daughter.
Yeah.
Cause I can relate to him just like,
just like I say this,
the store were,
were free reselling with the,
uh,
mental illness and stuff.
Like how people was mostly tired.
Like I got emotionally tied to our teams because he was a father that dealt with
a child with a disability as well as I,
so I know how hard it is to take care of children with disabilities.
And I know it takes a lot of money,
you know,
so I'm always for him,
I've,
I've been talking about him every since that time we fought,
win,
lose or draw.
I would've still been talking about him because of the,
the emotional ties that I had with them.
I understand them.
And when you understand the person,
you root for that person,
no matter what,
no matter who's side you on,
whatever,
when a person has something,
you feel like it's worser than the next person.
Or you can relate,
you know,
you,
you want them to win,
you know?
Now that's beautiful man.
And I think that,
uh,
having a guy like Ortiz,
as,
uh,
an opponent that's one of those fights that I think for a guy like you who
doesn't have a lot of amateur experience,
when you,
when you fight a guy that's that seasoned and you get to see like what it looks
like,
you get to see what it looks like when you're in the ring with a guy who's had
just as you said,
300 plus amateur fights overall.
That's a,
I mean,
that's an amazing learning opportunity,
right?
Oh,
most definitely.
Most definitely.
And um,
you know,
I just just had to confident that I was the,
I was the best.
I was,
no matter what he had always going with that confident though I blocked
everything that,
um,
his accomplishments in that we knew what we was up against,
you know,
but,
they was calling him to the Boogie or the division.
And at that point of time I still needed to prove myself because,
you know,
people still doubted me.
They,
you know,
I've been down with me from the start of my career and I was like,
since nobody don't want to fight them,
I want to bless him with this opportunity.
So these next moves that I made was to burn too then or teeth.
Then theory,
well there's to Vern highlight,
knockout was one of the most ridiculous all time.
When you stand there with your hands down,
step forward and it's like,
it was a comic book scene.
It's like the way you knocked him out.
Like I said about like you've been a bad guy in the movie.
It seemed like you were a bad guy in a boxing movie.
It didn't make any sense.
You were the guy.
Like if I was say if there's someone that was a,
I was a coach of a good guy and I was sitting ringside and I was watching you do
that,
we'd be like,
Shit.
Yeah,
okay.
I'm going to tell you,
man.
When I stood over them like that,
I was outside of my body.
I could see me and him standing there and be like,
I was a third person.
I can't explain it.
You know?
And then when I started throwing the punches,
like I went back into my body and start wailing on him or whatever.
I can't,
I can't explain that.
Why that feeling?
There's so many different things that happen.
One,
two,
because that got shared so much online.
That was the start of it.
Millions and millions of people saw that online and they're like,
what in the fuck is this guy got in his hands?
And that's when they started it.
Who is this guy?
We haven't heard about this guy before him.
It's like everybody's waking up to the heavyweight division.
All of a sudden it was so true and it was the perfect convert.
There it is.
I did dude play it from the beginning,
Jamie.
Here it goes.
Come on.
You know,
straight boxing skills.
I,
I got boxing skills.
You know,
when,
when I first photo,
I showed order it,
I stayed disciplined.
I didn't abandon the game plan and a,
you know,
and I showed people that I could box.
Yeah.
And he did.
That was probably the only time I just really just stayed super disciplined.
Not despite,
but it's the first one.
This part right here.
This one right here.
I went outside of my body right here.
I was standing.
Then I came back.
I kid you not.
I don't know what the hell was going on with me.
That was ridiculous.
It was ridiculous.
No he did.
Yeah he was uh,
he was quite upset.
That's the strangest little concoction he's got on his dreadlocks there.
Yeah.
Look like tape.
Yeah,
that seems like that would get in the way.
They keep it up,
you know Haitians believe in that too.
That was,
that was sweet too.
Then.
Then the referee get gummy riff.
I don't really
know.
It would have been funny to the with the Lego and he wrote to the other corner
and talk about a movie that would have been,
but you know that fight right there was the real start of it all.
You know,
in terms of public perception.
Exactly.
I knew I was really going somewhere with that,
especially when it went viral and then coming back with the rts.
Maybe cause the people,
it made that much more interesting to see what I'm going to do now.
Cause people tuned in now whether they they love me or hate me,
they tune in and see can I knock the next personnel.